[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen shown out
to the listeners and viewers but to the
man right to my right he came on a few
years ago and we're thrilled to have him
back talking about Rick and Morty's
returned to Adult Swim that happened
just a couple of nights ago season / 4
premiered last Sunday and it's on every
single Sunday night at 11:30 p.m.
Eastern and Pacific on Adult Swim
Saturday Night Live in 30 Rock alum
Chris Parnell back here in the rich I so
so good to see you sir good to see you
rich what do you get the most when
people say Chris Parnell what do you
what do you hear about the most
I know it's there's a lot of Rick and
Morty there's a lot of Archer there's a
lot of doctors but shemin's dr. spit
Chapman yeah from 30 rock 30 rock just
that is I miss 30 rock oh you bet you do
right I mean what is what an amazing fun
show that was it was now I've heard I've
heard a rumor that as they're doing a
spin-off with Ted Danson but I don't
know any details a 30 rock spin-off well
Ted Danson that's what I've heard but I
don't know if it's true well let's let's
start it like like let's let's do it
it's in a bar actually nobody's no no no
no that's that's that's cheers Chris
same family I guess right Church wrong
Pew would be this would be the we could
we could start it I thought I don't
think we're gonna be held accountable no
your if we start that rumor now 30 rock
you got involved with that through Tina
Fey and everybody else from the SNL Tina
Fey and Robert Carlock okay yeah yeah I
think they I think they had me in mind
for dr. Chaman
yeah okay cuz I'd work with them for
quite a few years at SNL and right yeah
I mean you'd that's what a gift you know
you don't get to do characters that are
that insane that often and just lines
that you could just chew up and just
have a good time with yeah well you know
you just try to you try to just say them
as Israel as naturally as possible you
know because the lines themselves do all
the work what do can you recall one
that's one of your favorite doctors but
jamming lines not to put you on the spot
even though by the way that's what
people do all the time
to put you on the spot even though I'm
not doing exactly that do you remember
anything well there was something about
he was talking to a patient I don't know
was Alec Baldwin or who but he pointed
out that no one knows where the human
heart is medically he got a lot of
things wrong a lot of things that as a
doctor should know you should know that
sort of thing you should know should
know most people know the things that
really doesn't know the human heart is
whatsoever Chris Parnell here on the
Rich Eisen show and again before we get
to Rick and Morty a little bit here I do
want to stroll down a little bit down
memory lane with you it's Saturday Night
Live one of the all-time greatest skits
you were in the cowbell sketch you know
what was your recollection of that being
put together and then the execution if
you will of it Chris well Will Ferrell
wrote it technically the name is
recording studio that's the that's the
name of discuss the name that he put on
the on the sketch on the script right
that we read that Wednesday at the table
read and I don't remember the
read-through or anything I'm sure it
went well but I just remember how much
fun everybody was having while we were
shooting the scene live when I was going
on and and I don't know it was you know
you can never predict when something's
gonna be a hit and have a longevity that
that's had but with walking with
Christopher Walken doing his thing so
perfectly he has such amazing comedic
instincts and he just he just sold it
perfectly you know and then and then
will is hilarious and yeah so how did
you get assigned to that I mean do you
get assigned to it or you whoever writes
the the piece or whatever team writes
the piece right you know they cast it
right and unless Lauren has a real
objection or something right way to you
know he just kind of has whoever they
put in the role so right willwill did
the casting so what what do you think
what what made everybody crack up the
most was it was it walkins
delivery his halting delivery about how
he makes gold plated records when he
wakes up or that wills belli began to
show
really laying here the cowbell Kris what
do you think I think I'd have to look at
it and break it down to be able to say
yes Authority yes I think it was both
you know I think it was both just what
we'll was doing around the set but you
know walking just killed it right I mean
it was amazing one of the best yeah were
you also in the colonel Angus
sketch as well with Christopher Walken
that's real that's right now I'm kind of
um I need to dance around the subject a
little bit here on this live broadcast
or were you concerned at all about that
episode sketch no not at all no no I
mean if it you know if the censors
hadn't said anything about it after the
table read you know and then you know we
did the dress rehearsal and right
nothing and so nothing yeah and then
you're like we're in the clear
did you were you thinking that we're
never gonna get this one on the air oh
no no no I felt pretty confident that it
was okay because Tina wrote it and it
was you know the way she crafted it and
you know is how could anybody say
anything about it you know did you ever
break it weren't you known as like the
Iceman or something like that on whoa
I'm Saturn I live like you never broke
correct I think so I don't think I did
well if you're not breaking in the
kernel Angus or the recording art was
recording studio recording studio yes
you can call it the cowbell the cowbell
sketch if you're not cracking up and
those usually you you're never gonna
break in that you know I tried not to I
tried to I tried to be in the moment you
know is that character and right I think
some people probably had a little more
fun in the moment than I did but uh yeah
I tried to I tried to hold it because
the one who's easiest though to break uh
Jimmy and Horatio when they were
together especially Jimmy Fallon for
sure
yeah they would really break and crack
each other up yeah but you never want I
mean you just asked me in my ear how do
you do that sort of thing
it's guess it's kind of like you can't
cheer in the press box is the only thing
that I can equate to anything that would
come with what I do is that you're not
allowed to you know scream or yell on
the press box and also just having no
joy inside exactly that's the that's the
that's the discovery that's the real
season
to planetary you're a hollow shell of a
man well it's just blackness in there
yeah pure darkness Chris Parnell here on
the Rich Eisen show why are you not on
Twitter or Instagram social media why
are you not on there Chris you know I
barely keep up with emails okay and when
all these other things came along it's
just like oh that's you know we started
with Facebook and it's like I don't want
that responsibility okay and then same
with Twitter and install of it it's just
like I don't you know so but you have
been on Twitter no never never no never
once never once okay I don't have a
Twitter and you never on any social
media at all
everyone I've got a like secret Facebook
account that I can go and like look at
my family Merlot or something you know
they're like like twice a year maybe Wow
as I told that you and Larry King got
into a beef is that a true story
now that's an odd thing for me to bring
up dancers coming back to do a 30 rock I
can just pretty much do all that how did
you get involved in the Seinfeld episode
of that what you had you did one
Seinfeld episode we talked about earlier
the butter shave episode yeah I mean you
know I was I hadn't been in LA that long
and I don't honestly know I I started to
get little guest our parts and reference
it comes and I think I had a manager in
an agent by that point and I came I
think I just went in and auditioned just
and just got the gig and what was it
like being on the SEVIS that the very
end it was the last season of Seinfeld
when you were there I know the whole I
know your whole life Chris even
including that that beef with Larry King
you think you didn't have that's
terrifying yeah no yeah it was it was
cool it was cool to be in the end I
guess it was the greenroom where
everybody was kind of hanging out and
Jerry Seinfeld was working on his lines
with somebody and yeah I mean it was
awesome to be a part of that
unbelievable show and now you're part of
Rick and Morty on Adult Swim season four
just premiered 11:30 p.m. Eastern and
Pacific why do you think this show works
in the way it does Chris well it's it's
the writing it's so much of it and then
they mean they take so much time to
craft each script and I mean that's why
there are so many delays and there's so
many you know long hiatuses because they
dan harmon and justin roiland really
just want to get it right and they've
put together an amazing team of writers
and then justin is pretty brilliant as
Rick and Morty you know so you got this
family unit which gives it some sense of
groundedness in reality yes and then
then they can just go anywhere and do
anything with the set up you know with a
portal gun they can go into any
dimension they can fly anywhere in the
universe and Rick spaceship and it's
it's no it's just it's a brilliant
premise and they and they write it
really well and does it ever confuse you
when you're just reading it on the page
and you need to because I'm imagining it
takes months for something like this to
actually be put together right
I think so yeah so you're just saying
your words and you're just you know then
you just go about your business being
Chris Parnell yeah I don't I know I
can't claim any responsibility for any
of the creative aspects of the show
right and what my voice does on it but I
uh yeah it's it's amazing yes it is
confusing sometimes what but usually
it's laid out clearly enough on the page
that I can follow it and then I'll
sometimes I'll think oh man the
animators have really got their work cut
out for them with this one because it's
gonna have 64 TV screens different you
know different realities going on at
once
sometimes and right massive and how do
we know how many more seasons of this
are gonna be made we may or this happily
Adult Swim ordered 70 episodes so I
think that includes the five right five
now and then the five it'll come in the
second half of season four right and
then yeah multiple seasons after that
going yeah that is fantastic if last one
for you from your entire characters that
you play what is your favorite voices or
people that you've imitated or anything
like was your favorite that you were
that you did Chris I'd probably have to
say doctors becomin yeah that was that
was pretty amazing
although Fred che I played a carrier
named Fred che with on a gas tire sit on
a gas tire on a ABC show called
Suburgatory and that was a lot of fun
that was that was pretty great just the
cast was awesome and fun role but dr.
Spach a man is in the clubhouse right
now absolutely
hey Chris thanks for coming on I don't
let's not do for years okay let's not
okay let's not because in the the
segment that we're gonna do television
only next play for Chris the drop you
you kindly did a drop for us yeah that
we've been using every single week when
Chris Brockman over there provides I
guess you've been using air quotes a lot
during this conversation let me use it
right here
gambling advice no offense Chris no
offense well our phrase it's called
sneaky good games with Chris Brockman
okay and you know we were thinking it's
better than a coin flip but watch what
should we use for it but this is what we
came up with and you knelt like we do
this every single week here on the rich
as your head with sneaky good games
contests likely to surprise you or their
heretofore undisclosed competitive and
the royalty checks must have gotten lost
in the mail sorry to say that's okay I
figure I'll collect them on my way out
nice party you for you that mug that log
is yours to keep it's a nice party gifts
for you for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app